un plafond révélé des détails retrouvez
après trois ans de travaux la chambre de
la reine et les trois autres pièces du
grand appartement s'ouvre au public un
lieu fréquenté par trois souveraine
la structure avec ses grosses bordure
reprend celle du temps de la reine marie
thérèse le décor a été très largement
remaniée pour la reine marie leczinska
au moment de la naissance du dauphin il
ya eu vraiment un changement de décor
complet donc l'ambiance générale de la
pièce je dirais plutôt louis 15 marie
leczinska mais marie antoinette pour sa
part a fait aussi beaucoup transformé la
pièce dans son ameublement un autre
appartement retrouve son décor celui
d'une presse que rennes à l'occasion
d'une commémoration
madame de maintenon meurt le 15 avril 10
719 le château propose une exposition
jusqu'au 21 juillet sur les pousses
secrète du roi louis xiv
elle ya vécu 35 ans est un lieu assez
emblématique puisque louis xiv lui a
octroyé cet appartement au moment où lui
donne une charge auprès de la dauphine
c'est à dire la brute de louis xiv il
trouve cette astuce pour lui donner un
appartement on a beau être la maîtresse
du roi on ne peut pas être logés
gratuitement à versailles le château met
aussi à l'honneur une reine dont on
parle peu marie leczinska souveraine
pendant 42 ans épouse de louis xiv la
reine polonaise se révèle à travers ses
goûts on voit aussi se dessiner un goût
pour certains peintres comme nattier
comme oudry on voit aussi se dessiner
son goût pour des sujets légers comme
des pastorales on met pas la même chose
dans le grand appartement d'apparat et
dans l'appartement intérieur et on voit
aussi se dessiner son goût pour la
conversation
elles forment autour d'elle un cercle
d'érudits trois visites trois lieux pour
découvrir celles qui ont marqué
l'histoire de france et l'histoire du
château